we continue our gameplay feature series
by exploring Middle Earth shadow of
Mordor nemesis system the Nemesis system
creates personal interactions with your
unique enemies every enemy will remember
their encounters with you in he'll got
your back just mine but yeah my coward
could try to flee to fight another day
why not
stayin around ladies another die
where'll oil captain could defend their
master to the death you work on my stuff
you got a come from me you like coming
throne' a warrior that strikes a death
blow against tallien will gloat in a
future encounter he's some kind of joke
they'll killed you already
every reaction is informed by a
combination of unique personality traits
and past interactions evolving the world
around you in surprising ways tell you
move we're all mace
I heard guy using the power of the
Wraith you may choose how to disrupt
surrounds war machine by creating power
struggles within orc society
girl the power of your forces by helping
them successfully complete missions
or bring down sarang's army from within
by commanding your enemies to battle one
another duels
these tonnes
feast side tear faced the Nemesis system
creates a living breathing dynamic work
society within Mordor
enabling every player to create their
own unique villains and stories
and ensuring no two playthroughs are
ever the same as you kill dominate and
terrify your way through the ranks of
Saiyans forces you can ultimately build
your own powerful army challenging the
Dark Lord and bending Mordor to your
will
you